[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well, welcome to tonight's last
lecture in the cosmic origins.
Thank you so much for
being here with us.
[APPLAUSE]
After tonight's
lecture, in six lectures
you will know as much as
our cosmologist, which
means that about 5%
of what's going on.
Today, I really felt like an
impresario in a nightmare.
Yesterday, we got a call from
our speaker, Carolyn Porco
saying that she
had had an accident
and that she was not
going to be here.
In fact, she's not here.
She's OK, but she
wasn't able to travel.
So then we went into panic mode.
And we figured out,
well, what can we do?
And we said, well,
maybe we could
have Peter Smith come and
talk to us about water on Mars
and talk about life on Mars.
And then we said,
well, maybe we can
have Jonathan Lunine
talk about his book,
How Do You Make A
Habitable Planet?"
Or we can go on to Roy
Parker and say, well,
how do we go from chemistry
to self-replicating chemistry?
Well, the timeline is
that we have a big bench.
And we decided,
though, in the end
that perhaps we should end the
talks with our star speaker
and that's with Chris Impey.
And Chris is going to give us
a lecture tonight-- [APPLAUSE]
and he'll tell us that
we know 5% of what's
out there about life.
Today, in particular,
I want to thank--
I hope you bear with me a
bit being the last lecture.
I want to thank
our underwriters,
those that make this possible,
the Arizona Daily Star, Cox
Communication, Bob Davis and
Innovation Park, Innovation
Park Place Stantic DPR,
those friends of the college,
the Galileo circle
members, Godat Design-- all
these beautiful things
are from Godat-- Raytheon.
Research Corporation
is special in this
as well because
they give us money
so that we can have the
funds to pay teachers
from middle and high school to
come and take credit for these
and take back to the classes.
So thank you for that.
[APPLAUSE] Unisource Energy
and Ventana Medical Systems.
And again, thank you all
for attending this as well.
[APPLAUSE]
Speaking of the teachers,
I just want to point--
and maybe they can stand
up-- but John Pollard who
is a faculty member
in chemistry,
and Margaret Wilch-- where's
Margaret-- from Tucson High
are the ones that have
actually got it all together.
But those are all the teachers
that are here with us.
Thank you so much.
And don't tell your students
that we don't know anything.
Actually, do tell them.
They have to figure it out.
We have a small lecture
series committee
that puts these things together
and tries to think them out.
And last year we
asked all of you
for your comments of what you
would like to hear from us.
And the great majority
of answer to us
were because of cosmology.
So we urge you to
let us know again
what topics you're interested in
and see if we can package them
together.
Carl Philabaum, who was
the person that actually
did that filling
of Centennial Hall,
and he's the one that also
has the funky pictures that
come out here.
He's a friend of the college,
and we thank him for that.
The Arizona Public Media
for filming these lectures.
They now have been highlighted
in YouTube, not YouTube, iTunes
as something worthy to look at.
And Stuart Glogoff, who
actually posts the podcast.
I do encourage you all to look
for these and past lectures
in the College of
Science website.
Starizona for making
a contribution
towards a telescope drawing.
And everybody from the College
of Science has to not drawn.
So only you folks
can actually get it.
And Centennial Hall staff
has made it possible
for us to do this as
well as been working.
So thanks to all.
[APPLAUSE]
And for those of you that
cannot get enough astronomy,
there is actually
a lecture series.
Stuart is offering it.
You have to go to the website
and see when that starts.
It starts actually
beginning March 28
and it runs throughout
the semester.
So between the telescope
in Mount Lemmon
and the lecture series
of Stuart Observatory
you can continue learning
about our cosmos.
And I just want to do one
special thing right now.
There are, amazingly
enough, young kids
from middle school and some
even from elementary school
that are coming here to listen
to these lecture series.
And I've met a few of
them here and there.
And of course, since I'm old,
I don't remember their names.
But I did remember two of them.
And I'd like to ask
them to come up here.
It's Alfredo and Alex
Diaz, come up here--
are you around by any chance?
Come up here.
I want to give
you a certificate.
[APPLAUSE]
And the rest of you that
I didn't get to meet,
if you just let me
know who you are,
I'll give you a
certificate later on.
But thank you so much.
And Chris--
[APPLAUSE]
It's great to be
back, although not
under these circumstances
necessarily, but sometimes
life throws you a curve.
I talk to Carolyn.
And she's fine.
She has the penalty of living
in a place where there's ice.
I try and-- [LAUGHTER] I try
and rule ice out of my life.
That's why I live here.
And you just have to go with
the flow in these things.
Things don't always go
exactly as you want.
And they change.
And you have to be willing to
adapt to the circumstances.
My caveat, as I start, is
that I'm not an astrobiologist
and I'm not a
planetary scientist.
I have a hobby, side
interest, in that.
The research I do is if
it's closer than a billion
light years, I don't care.
So that includes everything I'm
going to talk about tonight.
But I really care a
lot about everything
I'm going to talk about tonight.
So I and we all, I'm
sure, wish Carolyn well.
She's fine.
But she did take a nasty fall.
So she's not able to be here.
Now since it's not my subject
matter, that's the big caveat.
And I'll follow this very
well understood process
in the upper
echelons of academia,
where you say basically
any [NO AUDIO]
want and people won't know.
And before I start, I want
to make one public service
announcement.
There should be no guns in here.
[APPLAUSE]
Now as you know,
that may not last.
I'm just telling you that if I
come back here in a future date
and you are packing heat,
I am going to pack heat.
I'm going to pack
more heat than you.
I'm going to pack so much heat.
I'll scare you, OK?
So just let's have that clear,
because there's a lot of you,
OK?
Thank you.
So the subject matter tonight is
in Carolyn's title, "The Oldest
Question," the oldest and
perhaps one of the most
profound questions about
the universe we live in,
which is whether this
extraordinary experiment
in biology that took
place in this one little
remote cubby hole, this
little corner of the universe,
starting four billion
years ago, is unique.
That's an extraordinarily
profound and simple question.
The architect and visionary
Buckminster Fuller
put it very nicely, that
dichotomy, either we are alone
in the universe or we're not.
Either way the implications
are staggering.
And they really are.
And so what you see is the
end of a long progression
that is the Copernican
revolution, which
continues to this day.
And as we see,
it's a progression
of ignominy, where
we find ourselves
to be an exceptional
in our position
relative to an average star
within an average galaxy in one
region of the universe
filled with galaxies.
We also find we're not
even made of the that
the universe is
overwhelmingly made of.
And perhaps the final steps
in the Copernican revolution,
this progression of displacement
of us in importance,
would be one that I
alluded to in my talk,
the possibility
of other universes
beyond our view
and the possibility
that there are other habited,
inhabited, not just habitable,
but habited planets
elsewhere in the universe.
So that's a subject for tonight.
And of course, you
know already this
is a talk with lousy tension
because you know the answer.
I'm not going to break
the news to you tonight.
We are still the
only living planet
we know of in the universe.
So I'll just leave
a little while
for you to leave if you
want, because I just gave you
the answer.
That's the answer.
We're it.
So we'll just be staring
at our navels this evening
and just being very happy that
we're alive, because we don't
know of anywhere else that is.
But the game is
getting interesting.
And I hope I can
persuade you that not
just in distant future.
But in the proximate
future in our lifetimes,
we may learn the answer
to this question,
an extraordinary
question to answer.
But first let me reiterate that
it is a subject in its infancy.
And the amount we
know vastly exceeds
what we don't in a similar
way to the universe contents.
For example, the
biosphere, the thing
that we should know the best,
we don't fully understand.
Most of the microbial
diversity of the biosphere
is unexplored, untapped.
Those microbes are
uncultured in the lab.
We really don't
understand them very well.
We've only poked
around the solar system
with our robotic
and remote sensing
probes in a few locations.
We have explored or even
diagnosed in the simplest way
a tiny fraction of the habitable
real estate in the Milky Way
galaxy.
And the activity of
SETI, the abbreviation
for the Search for
Extraterrestrial Intelligence,
is in its infancy, and
as they would admit,
have only searched
a tiny fraction
of all the possible
stars that could have
planets sending signals to us.
So this is a subject where we're
just starting to get going.
The context for life in the
universe is fairly simple,
and you've heard it built up
in stages in previous talks,
the first part is, of course,
chemistry and also the fact
that there are places
where life can exist.
So we understand that as a
natural by product of star
formation planets will form.
It's an unexceptional
physical process.
Collapsing clouds of gas
and dust form a disk.
Most of the mass
goes into the star.
A small fraction is left
over and forms rocky objects
that glom together by accretion.
Radiation from the young star
drives out the residual gas.
And so you end up with
small rocky objects
near the star and
larger, cooler objects,
which can accrete gassy
envelopes further out.
Those are the gas giants.
Turns out that's maybe a
little bit of a just so
story to explain
our solar system,
because the planets we've
started to find elsewhere
do not follow this
simple picture.
But certainly we expect
planets to form naturally
wherever stars form.
And that's what
we've been finding.
We also know that the
ingredients for life
are widespread.
So you might worry in the
business of astrobiology
whether the
requirement that life
be made with carbon and use
water is overly restrictive.
And I would say, no.
I would say we should
open our minds to life
that doesn't have that basis.
But there's no need
to look beyond that,
because as you
can see, carbon is
one of the most abundant
elements in the universe.
Made in stars.
Distributed into the
space between stars.
The long journey of all the
carbon atoms in our bodies
probably encompasses
dozens or even
hundreds of generations
of stars over cosmic time,
an extraordinary story.
Each carbon atom has a
different story in fact.
But the ingredient is there.
And water is one of the
most abundant molecules
in the universe.
So even if we say that
life needs those things,
that is not restrictive
in a cosmic sense.
Also, the universe has been
getting more fit for life
as cosmic time passes, because
stars have been progressively
been making more carbon.
And so the fact that we
live in an ancient universe
should not surprise us because
we couldn't exist in a universe
100 million years
after it formed,
even though there
were stars then.
They were pristine stars made
only of hydrogen and helium
with no planets around them.
There was no grit
to grow the pearl.
And so back in
the early universe
there probably was no life.
So the ingredients
are widespread.
And the ingredients
are put out there
by cycles of star
birth and death.
And you've heard some about
that in previous lecture.
So these heavy elements are
cooked inside stars by fusion,
are ejected into
interstellar space,
where they become part of
a new generation of stars.
And this cyclic process
of star birth and death,
the creation of heavy elements
by fusion deep inside stars.
Of course, all of
these fusion events
happened at least 4 and
1/2 billion years ago
because they preceded
the formation
of the Earth and the sun.
So this is a life
story of stars.
But it's also our life story.
It's the story of our
life, of our biology.
And they couldn't exist.
If stars were selfish and
hoarded their heavy elements
in their cores and just
shrunk into stellar corpses
with no return of heavy elements
to the universe at large,
there would be no biology.
Now we have an
immediate problem,
and as a non-biologist,
it's easy for me
to point to it very strongly.
Biologists know what they study.
But if we're talking
about life in the universe
we're worrying about the
general case of something
where we know one instance.
And that's a difficult
position to be in.
And defining life
is just difficult.
For the professional
biologist it's difficult.
For astrobiologist,
perhaps even more so.
Because if you ask that life
have organizing principles
and complex and interesting
behavior, you might imagine
you know what biology
would look like sight
unseen in another world,
but it's not obvious
what it would look like.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[RUMBLING SOUND]
So if we saw that happening on
the surface of an alien planet,
we'd probably get quite excited.
But there's no biology there.
There's not even chemistry.
That's just physics.
That's just flour, water, a
pie tray, and a bass speaker.
So we're trying to broaden
the envelope of biology.
We don't yet know
whether, even where
they're at the micro
level of the genetic code
or at the macro level
of natural selection,
biology operates anywhere
other than the Earth.
We suppose and
hope that it might,
because it will add
to our understanding
when we discover
something interesting.
But the truth is we have to be
open for other possibilities.
And we have to play
this interesting game
of asking about hypotheticals,
because those hypotheticals
might exist in the universe.
We have to ask what might be
and doesn't violate any laws
of physics or chemistry or
even our knowledge of biology,
but isn't.
Things that could happen
but don't here but
might happen elsewhere.
That's a difficult thing to do.
When we're starting with talking
about life in the universe,
we have to be very clear
about what life on Earth is
and isn't.
Probably to non-biologist,
the most striking thing
is that everything from a fungus
to a great whale to a butterfly
is all one thing.
Life on Earth is one thing.
And that one thing has
the same genetic code,
the same biochemical basis.
And it's basis of course is DNA.
The tree of life used to be
defined in terms of species.
The diversity of species dating,
of course, back before Darwin.
But the modern tree of life is
based on the genetic material.
It's based on the
gradual divergence
from a hypothetical last common
ancestor, perhaps 4 billion
years ago on the Earth,
where time moves forward
in the upward
direction, and where
genetic diversity is represented
by distance along this tree.
This is very different from a
tree of life based on species,
because humans, if we
could put humans on this,
we are smaller than the dot
on the eye of the animals.
So we are the tiniest little
twiglet on the tree of life.
And most of the real estate
of biological and genetic
diversity and metabolic
diversity is in microorganisms.
This is a microbial
world, and we
our little outriggers, maybe
small, unlikely contingent
outcomes of evolution.
We don't know.
But that's the way
the world looks.
And so that's the context
for understanding life
in the universe.
This is quite surprising
at some level.
We share this
percentage-- or these
are the number of
deviant nucleic acid,
so the amount of genetic
material overlap.
And you may drink
your beer and think
that it's just a nice beverage
and something that you
relax with.
But it actually has kinship with
you at almost the 50% level.
So you are not that
different from your beer.
And so it's striking that such
a small amount of difference
in genetic material--
it's no good
playing the Guinness
Book of Records game.
If you want to make us best
because we have more base pairs
or more genes, it's not true.
So you have to look somewhere
else for why we're special.
So this becomes a context
for life in the universe
too if what happened on
the Earth was not unusual.
Now the very difficult
question of can
we tell the story of how
life on Earth started?
That, of course, would
be a whole lecture.
It's not clear.
We cannot connect all the
dots between the simple small
molecules that were abundantly
available in interstellar space
and on the primordial Earth to
the first cell or proto cell.
We cannot.
But in different
lab experiments,
pieces of this story
have been told,
even to the level of
self-catalyzing fragments
of RNA to the spontaneous
formation of vessels that
have some of the properties
of very small cells
and to the creation of
small concentrated chemical
reactors, which is
at some level what
a cell is before it gets going.
But none of these produce
replicating molecules that
would hold the genetic code.
None of these produce anything
recognizable as a modern cell.
So this is a story, this
is historical science.
And we may never be able to
tell fully the story of how
life on Earth started uniquely.
And we may have
to just face that.
Life on Earth is telling us
something else about what
to expect in the universe.
And that's by looking at the
boundaries of life on Earth.
So we kind of are
proud of ourselves
because we can live most places.
We live in Alaska.
We live in the desert
here and so on.
But basically, we're
ridiculously frail wusses.
We're just pathetic.
Life on Earth is much
more hardy than we are.
And the hardiness is
all in microbial hands.
So there are small
microorganisms
that live-- you may
say life needs water,
but life lives in
places where it
hasn't rained for 100 years,
the high Atacama Desert.
We imagine that
life needs water.
But life can actually invent
its own kind of antifreeze
and so exists quite happily
below the freezing point
of water.
Life can exist above the
boiling point of water too.
And entire ecosystems were
found near hydrothermal vents
in the 1970s in total
darkness at pressures
of hundreds of atmospheres,
super heated water
and at some level
independent of sunlight.
So saying that life needs
a star is clearly wrong,
because all it needs is an
energy source, in this case,
geothermal energy.
Life can handle incredible
radiation doses.
This is deinococcus
radiodurans, which could happily
absorb 1,000 times the radiation
dose that would drop us dead,
stone dead, in
about five seconds.
And it does so by keeping
stacked copies of its DNA
to repair its DNA at a rate
hundreds or thousands of times
faster than we can.
So these are all
adaptations of life,
which is permeated almost every
conceivable ecological niche
on the Earth, and maybe
some that are inconceivable.
Life has been found--
rich, diverse,
microbial cultures have
been found in mines
that were closed by the EPA.
They have toxic run-off,
cadmium, mercury, silver,
very, very toxic
heavy elements to us.
But microbes can
metabolize these.
They can gain their
energy from them.
And they exist
quite happily, also
with other extreme
conditions of high salinity
or acidity, super
heated water, and so on.
And then surprises continue, a
few years ago, a small microbe
was found deep in a
mine in South Africa.
It appears to be
an ecosystem of one
living in the bathe radiation
glow of a totally dark mine
shaft.
And there are some
estimates that
say that 90% of the
biomass of this planet
is indeed below the Earth's
surface in microbial forms,
perhaps like this.
So that's a context for
life in the universe.
And not all of these are
tiny and may be a little
uninteresting to us, microbes.
Here's an extremophile,
as they're called,
which is visible.
It's pretty small.
It's about the size of the head
of a pin or a little smaller.
It's a tardigrade, known
to children as water bear.
And there are 700
different species of it.
It has its own phylum.
And it's quite a
complex organism.
It has this amazing
trick of cryptobiosis,
going into a freeze dried state
and rolling into a little ball
where it can be carried on
the wind or an animal fur.
And the chemistry, the
biochemistry, of this process
is being studied in labs as
a way of learning perhaps
how we might get suspended
animation as something that we
can do to ourselves.
So pulling some of
these things together,
what is the
expectation in advance
of finding life anywhere
else-- remember,
it hasn't been found--
that life will be common?
We'd have to have some reason
for that level of confidence
without any evidence whatsoever.
And the reasons are here.
First, that life appeared
very early in the history
of the Earth, when
the earth was really
a very inhospitable place
with impact [? SEAM ?]
rates thousands of
times what they are now,
intense vulcanism, an
unbreathable atmosphere,
life began.
The motor of life ticked
over very, very early indeed.
We know that the
basic ingredients
can combine to form the
next level of ingredients,
even if we can't
tell all that story.
And then the
extremophiles tell us
that given the
physical boundaries,
the physical conditions
that bound life on Earth,
it is expanded to fill almost
all of those conditions.
It doesn't just go
for the happy middle
or the comfortable
place, not like us.
We want a nice beach
house in Hawaii.
And then we're happy.
We don't want to go
to those hard places.
Well, life goes to the
hard places and does fine.
We know the ingredients
are everywhere.
And as I'll talk about,
there are abundant sights
where life might form.
So everything's there.
It's like the table is set
in the universe for life.
And now we want to know
if anyone's at the dinner.
Let's start in the solar
system, the nearest
place we can look in
some level of detail.
And of course, we start
with the place we've
looked most closely, Mars.
[MEDLEY OF SONGS FEATURING MARS
PLAYING]
The basic story of Mars
is told in this picture
from the highrise camera,
which is operated out
of the Lunar and Planetary
Lab, or just down the mall,
by the University of Arizona.
It's a dry desert,
for the most part.
Water cannot exist on
the surface of Mars.
If you put a cup of
water there right now,
it would evaporate and boil
away in a fraction of a second.
So there is no water on Mars.
But Mars has done more
than tantalize us.
It's told us that it
is an interesting place
to look harder.
And of course, we've done more
than do it with the orbiters.
We've done it with rovers.
Although for the life of me, I
don't know why they didn't just
turn left a little
bit here, why they
got stuck behind that boulder.
I don't know.
It's NASA.
Don't ask, OK.
But not to mock NASA at
all, we were recently
celebrating both a bittersweet
celebration, six and seven
years for the Mars rovers,
Spirit and Opportunity.
Spirit almost certainly
is trapped forever.
I was at JPL a week ago, and
they have this sad mock-up
of Spirit full sized
with its wheels
completely covered in sand that
it's never going to get out.
So Spirit, I think,
is truly dead.
Opportunity rolls on.
So we can just take
a moment to celebrate
Spirit and an incredible amount
that it's told us about Mars.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Spirit and Opportunity
between them
have provided abundant
geochemical evidence
that water existed on
the surface of Mars.
We've had some of this
evidence for decades.
The first orbiters
produced pictures
that even to the untutored are
just reminiscent of running
water, river deltas, shallow
basins where water once sat.
But the models of Mars
suggest that Mars could not
have held liquid
water for a long time,
perhaps two to three
billion years ago.
And that's a little
disappointing.
So finding life there
would be perhaps fossilized
microbial life, very difficult
to do with the rovers
that we have currently there
or even the ones planned.
As I said, Mars tantalizes us.
This pair of pictures taken
less than four years apart
show that it's not just
ancient water on Mars.
Mars has water now.
Episodically and in
very small locations,
water erupts under the
surface, as we speak.
Somewhere on Mars water is
probably erupting right now.
You're seeing the
edge of an escarpment
in these pair of pictures.
And before the second picture,
in the best models of this,
about 300 swimming
pools worth of water
erupted from a
subsurface aquifer
through to the edge
of an escarpment
and then ran down
the sandy hillside,
carving out this channel, and
then evaporated into space.
So the best modeling
suggests that there
is liquid water right now under
Mars, 10, 50, 100 meters down.
We don't know how far down.
And of course, where there
is water, kept liquid,
in this case, by pressure from
above and radioactive heating
from below, there is, of
course, the possibility of life.
So while Mars is mostly
dead on its surface,
underground there could be life.
Unfortunately, the
current generation
of instruments and rovers
is incapable of digging
more than scratching the surface
more than a few centimeters
down.
So we're going to have
to use some ingenuity
to get to these places.
And in fact, there
enough missions
planned for Mars
that it's actually
going to get pretty crowded.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[ZAPPING SOUND]
[WHIRRING SOUND]
[METAL CLANKING]
[THUMPING]
[CREAKING SOUND]
[YAWNING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
Planets are
interesting for life.
But what we've learned
in the last few decades
is that the moons of the
giant planets, not the giant
planets themselves
because they're mostly
hydrogen and helium.
They're made of what
the sun is made of.
They may have rocky cores.
But those rocky cores are
probably very inhospitable.
But some of the moons of the
giant planets are equal in size
to the small planets of
the inner solar system.
They have separate sources
of heating from tidal flexing
caused by their parent planet.
And so satellites or moons
have become just as exciting
to look for life in the solar
system as terrestrial planets.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What you're looking at is the
fractured ice floe surface
of Europa, one of the
Galilean moons of Jupiter.
The smallest features seen
here, about 100 meters across.
So this is a
torturous landscape,
which sequence the imaging
indicates it is moving.
It's flexing like
an ice floe would
that has liquid beneath it.
And the best models
for Europa suggest
that it has a 500 meter
to kilometer thick ice
crust on top of a tens
of kilometer deep ocean.
So this is a water world, fully
covered water world under ice.
And although it's
extremely cold,
there is a tepid heating
source from the moon itself,
from geological heating.
And so this is a
cryogenic biosphere issue.
There are many places we're
finding in the universe
where it's pretty cold.
But it's not so cold that we
couldn't imagine low levels
of biological activity.
In fact, there are
missions planned
to go under, to go under
by landing on the ice pack,
using heating from a
nuclear power plant
to melt through and release
a hydro bot to look for life.
This mission is
currently unfunded.
But NASA's had the
design for a decade.
Another fascinating
place to go--
we've got a taste of
in 2005-- is Titan.
And you look at the
surface of Titan,
and it is terrestrial
in appearance.
There are not just dry or
arid river deltas as on Mars,
there are river deltas
with liquid in them.
There are shallow seas.
There are clouds.
There's cryovolcanism.
It's an active moon.
It's a moon with an
atmosphere thicker
than the air your
breathing, made of mostly
the same stuff, nitrogen.
Here's what the
lakes of Titan look
like from the radar imaging.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Titan is the only planetary
body besides Earth
that we know has lakes.
At 290 degrees
Fahrenheit below zero,
the only liquid that makes
sense there is a combination
of methane and ethane.
This lake is Ontario Lacus on
Titan's southern hemisphere.
It's a little smaller
than Lake Michigan.
We've colored the
lake black, because we
think that's probably its real
color, although we don't really
know for sure.
We've exaggerated the heights
of the shoreline features
to make them easier to see.
Notice these hills,
probably made of water ice.
See how the liquid has
flooded up the valleys.
Further north is a
long smoother beach
that looks like it's
been shaped by waves.
You can see some
lines along the beach
that might be old shorelines,
like bathtub rings.
So we know the level of
the lake has changed.
Now we're turning east to
a very obvious bay that
cuts into the beach.
So it's likely to be younger.
We'll cross over the lake.
You'll see some flooded valleys.
And in the background is a
large river that makes a delta,
like the Mississippi River.
It's shape means the lake is
shallow and the river is slow.
Ontario's shore is surprisingly
like Earthly lake shores,
pretty amazing to find
something this Earth
like 800 million miles.
[END PLAYBACK]
Another place we'd
love to go back to,
NASA has a mission planned
for this too, also unfunded
and at least a decade away.
Planetary scientists, my
colleagues over at LPL
are somewhat frustrated
by the long timelines
of doing these missions.
But you are going
a good fraction
of a billion miles, high
degree of difficulty,
expensive, always
a risk of failure.
But some people think,
although we don't know,
that ethane, methane, plus
some water in ammonia,
especially below the
surface, is a plausible basis
for a very strange and
unusual kind of biochemistry.
If there was life 2.0,
this might be the place
we find it in the solar system.
And then we've been
surprised by the fact
that there's water in
places we never anticipated.
Tiny little Enceladus,
500 kilometers across,
no bigger than Rhode
Island, a far too small moon
to be interesting to most
planetary scientists,
turns out to have geysers that
are sprouting to the surface
and then ejecting ice particles
into space, where they've
been sampled from
Cassini and shown
to contain salt and other
interesting chemicals.
And if you do a full census
of all of the small bodies
in the outer solar system
that might have the three
ingredients for life, the bare
minimum, organic material,
liquid water, and
available energy,
the number is about a dozen.
Most of them are unexceptional
moons of the giant planets.
And the liquid water, of
course, is under the surface
in these cases.
But that's a pretty
interesting inventory.
So it's certainly not just
Mars that's a potential place
for microbial life
in the solar system.
But in the last 15
years, we've started
to discover planets elsewhere.
So rather than just
looking in our backyard,
we have a whole vast
amount of new real estate
to inspect for life.
Now this is very early days.
We only started to find planets
beyond the solar system,
as I said, 15 years ago.
And they came in a dribble.
Now they're becoming a flood.
And they're starting to get
what I would call interesting
in their nature.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
These planets, when we
started to find them,
surprised us, because
they were usually
large massive, more massive than
Jupiter, ON incredibly tight
orbits of their parent stars.
So we started to look
around Sun-like stars,
hoping to find proxies
for the solar system.
And what we found was
really quite different.
Here's an example.
This is a system, actually
the first solar system found,
a system of four
gas giant planets,
and a little
visualization of where
it exists in the
constellation of cancer,
looking out in that direction
to the 55th brightest
star in the constellation.
If you visualize
leaving our solar system
and then doing a
little warp speed
thing about 40 light years, you
end up in another star system.
And there four planets
sit, going around
their sun-like star.
They're all between the
masses of Neptune and Saturn.
The record holder now is a
system with seven planets.
And given that Pluto
has been demoted,
that's almost as many
planets as our solar system.
So this is becoming
very mature science.
We're finding systems
of planets, mostly still
large planets.
This is the story so far.
530, I looked it up last
night, 531 exoplanets.
In 1995, none.
All in the last 15 years.
And you can see several things.
First, you can see that
most of these planets
are still massive.
They're still Jupiter-like
or even more massive.
But the detection
limit, the threshold
of the smallest
thing we can detect
has marched steadily downward
and is reaching Earth mass,
just last year essentially.
The game is just getting
really interesting.
The record holder,
Gliese 581e, is just
under twice the
mass of the Earth.
So we're starting to go from
gas giants, which we would never
expect to be habitable, although
their moons might be-- we just
don't have a way of
finding their moons-- down
towards terrestrial planets,
things that are Earth-like.
And I'll come back to
that space in a minute.
The method has been
indirect detection.
A planet around a nearby star
reflects about 100 millionth
of the light, if it's an earth,
a billionth of the light.
And it sits so
close to the star,
it's like trying to see a
firefly next to the floodlights
of Arizona Stadium.
So the method that was used
was an indirect method,
where we look for the
wobble induced on a star
by the orbiting massive planet.
In the case where that happens
in the equatorial plane,
we get an extra way
of detecting it.
We get the Doppler shift
from the wobble of the star.
And we also get a
periodic eclipse,
where the light from
the star dims according
to the size of the planet.
And that works like this.
For Jupiter crossing
a sun-like star,
the brightness will dip
for about five hours,
in fact, once every
12 years by about 1%.
That's easy to detect.
Earth will make a signal
100 times smaller, so
a hundredth of a percent.
And that sounds hard,
but that can be done.
And that's what the Kepler
satellite was designed for.
And I'll show you the
results from that.
So this has become a
very powerful technique
for not only measuring planets
and finding their mass,
but also the size of the
planet, because the depth
of the eclipse tells you
the size of the planet.
And size plus a mass
gives you a density.
So you learn something extra.
And what we've
learned is that nature
makes an extraordinary
variety of planets.
Almost everything that
theorists could hypothesize
has been found at this point.
We've not really found
pure water planets.
But we've found planets
that are probably 50% or 60%
water ice and the rest rocks.
We found planets that
are 80% or 85% metal,
mixed in with little rock.
So extraordinary composition
variations of planets.
And indeed many are
just like the sun
and are mostly
hydrogen and helium.
So it's a kind of a
wild world out there.
And the level of
information is not always
what we might want
to discriminate
between these possibilities.
The goal, of course,
is to detect earths.
That's when it gets interesting.
So let me give you the
state of that game.
Here's what simulations tell us.
This is a simulation
where things
that are hundredth
the Earth mass,
planetesimals, are
gradually glomming together
by gravity, just by simple
accretion of running
into each other and
sticking by gravity,
into a small number
of large things.
And so this is a simulation,
a full gravity simulation.
And you can see how quickly,
starting from small chunks,
you build up the
Earth-like planets.
This is a simulation,
of course, and it's not
expected that you generate
the inner solar system.
But you can run this simulation
hundreds or thousands of times
and see the diversity
of terrestrial planets.
And what you find when you
run all these simulations is
pretty much what you see here.
That in general you
get between 2 and 5
rocky terrestrial planets.
And typically 10% to 20% of
them are in the habitable zones
of their stars.
So simulation, pure
theory, is telling
you should expect essentially
all sun-like stars to have
a couple of rocky
planets and 10% roughly
of them to be in
the habitable zone
and therefore potentially
have liquid water.
So a very exciting number.
But that's theory.
What does the data say?
Here's the data from just
a month ago from the Kepler
satellite finally releasing
Earth-like planets
for the first time.
So you saw the 15-year
history of this object
until a month ago.
Here's the data that NASA
released in a press conference
quite recently.
Kepler is looking for
these small eclipses.
And because it can detect
a very subtle eclipse,
it can find earths.
And the proof is right here.
But Kepler has only been
working for a few months.
And so these Earth-like
planets are, of course,
in orbital periods of a
month, maybe two months.
So they're going around their
stars faster than mercury.
And so they're
hotter than Mercury.
So we have to be patient.
We have to wait until Kepler
has worked for a couple of years
before it can find an Earth
in an Earth-like orbit.
But this tells you that
they're there to be found.
We just have to be patient for
the satellite to bring them in.
And the other exciting
thing from these results
is that the number of
planets increases rapidly
towards the detection limit.
So for every Jupiter
or Saturn-like planet,
you actually expect
many Earth-like planets.
Rocky, terrestrial
planets are abundant.
They're not rare at all.
Going back to simulations,
the simulations
allow us to follow the
water in a simulation.
So we can see where these rocky
planets what water content they
have.
And you might think the
Earth is a water planet.
We think the Earth is special.
We talk about it
as the water world
and think that it's
special for that reason.
And certainly Mars is
dry and Venus baked dry.
But these simulations
tell us that, in general,
terrestrial planets will
have as much as the inventory
of the Earth's oceans,
maybe even 10 times as much,
maybe 100 times as much.
Remember, water is not
of rare ingredient.
So we have everything we need.
We have abundant,
rocky planets beginning
to be found by Kepler.
We have some fraction of
them, a significant fraction,
in a habitable zone where liquid
water can be on the surface.
And models tell us that that
liquid water will be there.
It will be part of the
composition of the planet.
It's very exciting.
It's just a matter of time
before we pull in an Earth.
What's the next
step of the game?
The next step of the
game is, of course,
to look for signs for life.
These planets are dozens
of light years away.
They're impossibly faint to
observe with our telescopes.
The best we can do is take that
feeble light a billion times
fainter than the star it orbits
and spread it into a spectrum
and try and look for what
are called biomarkers.
That is the signatures
and spectroscopy
of elements we think are
connected with biology.
So you can see from the
comparison with Mars and Venus,
where the major imprint in
their atmosphere in the infrared
is carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere.
Earth has that imprint too.
But it has the extra
signature of ozone.
It's a stronger
signal than water
it turns out in the infrared.
That's what you look for.
And, of course, it has water.
And ozone is a biomarker.
Oxygen is a biomarker.
Methane, much of which is
produced by biology on Earth
in our atmosphere at a
trace level, is a biomarker.
This is the next
stage of the game,
to take the best of those
Earths and use our very biggest
telescopes on the
ground and in space--
this is very light
hungry, this kind of work.
It's why we're building
the GMT down in Chile.
It's why we built the
LBT interferometer here
on Mount Graham is to
do this kind of work.
It's why the James
Webb Space Telescope
is being planned to succeed
the Hubble Space Telescope.
All of these big
facilities are going
to do this kind of science.
And that's going to
be the next step.
And that may be indeed in
the next five to 10 years
how we learn that we think
we found a terrestrial planet
with the signature of biology.
Remember, on the Earth, if
life disappeared overnight,
if biosphere went
dead overnight,
the 20% of the air you're
breathing that's oxygen
would disappear in a
million years, which
is geologically a blink of an
eye, because oxygen, of course,
is very reactive.
It will just rust everything
and go into seawater and so on.
And so oxygen is only maintained
on a planetary time scale
by biology, in our experience.
And that's why we think
it's a good biomarker.
Just to put a little
sobering thought on this.
We might think, oh, great
we'll have an Earth.
That will be a place where
can go in case things
go south here.
No, I don't think so.
Well, Earth 2.0 is not going
to be exactly like Earth.
When we talk about
Earth clones, of course,
we're talking about
similar, not identical.
And I don't think
any of it relieves us
of the need to take
care of our planet,
because these nearest Earth-like
planets are likely from Kepler
to be actually dozens of light,
maybe even hundreds or 200
light years away.
There is no way we
are ever going there
in any conceivable time scale.
They're beyond our
reach for travel,
for colonization, for voyaging,
even for joyrides in the future
that any of us can see.
So we've got to look
after this planet.
So that's the state of
the game for microbes.
That's where we think
we'll look for--
[SNORING]
Oh, OK, microbes, who cares?
Now come on, it's pond scum.
It's the stuff you scrape
off your shower curtain.
It's yeast.
Please.
Why am I boring you with this?
This is not what life in
the universe is about.
Life in the universe
is about companionship.
It's about, are we alone?
Let's get real here.
OK, now I'm going to get real.
Where are the aliens?
OK, let's get to the real thing.
I've done that crappy
boring science stuff.
You know, OK, this is
how we find microbes.
But we really are
going to do it.
Now let's go up the chain a bit.
But I'm still going to stay
with microbes a little bit,
because microbes should
get dissed a lot.
You know, microbes are kind
of interesting, even for me
as a kind of physical scientist.
So we tend to underestimate--
we think we're very smart
and we have technology
and all that stuff.
But if we're starting to
look for intelligent life
in the universe,
high functioning,
technological life,
life with brains,
we've got to get our
reference points.
And once again, the Earth
is our reference point.
And I'll just make
the obvious comment
that microbes have figured
out some pretty clever things,
like they figured out
how to make nanowires
before we ever did in a lab.
They can sense magnetic fields.
They can operate commensally
and in cooperation.
They can exchange signals
with reasonable bit
rates, some forms of
chemical communication.
That's pretty clever.
If you go up the
chain a bit to things
that are beneath your
contempt, for the most part,
you might notice that
termites build mounds
that scale to
[? SEAM ?] the organism
are bigger than our
tallest skyscrapers.
And they have five different
temperature control mechanisms
built into the composites
of natural substances
that they put together
to make these things.
That's pretty cool.
And social insects,
obviously, you
can just say they're all
hardwired by evolution
and they don't have any
choice in the matter.
But viewed from afar,
again, if you're
trying to distinguish
intelligence
and non-intelligence,
it's not an easy call,
because they do have
stratification of communication
and highly organized
functioning that
is adaptive to their
situation, their environment.
And I think the point is
not whether ants or termites
or social insects are smart.
The question is that evolution
does not stand still.
We view the natural
world and the organisms
we share the planet with
at a snapshot of time,
where we happen to
be king of the hill
and we are able to
look down on them
and say, well, yeah that's fine,
but you don't have cell phones.
Come on, please.
Please come back when you
have wireless internet
and then we'll talk.
You are not
sophisticated, please.
So that's what we think about.
But the truth is evolution
doesn't stand still.
If we screw up
this planet, which
we're sort of doing
in the margins
and we're not here in a
million years, fair bet,
I want to see what insects
have done in 100 million years.
Remember, there's many, many
millions of species of them.
There's more of them
than there are of us.
And they're doing their thing
quite happily and quite nicely.
And, of course, you
talk about technology.
Let me just diminish that
envelope a little bit.
Technology, yeah,
we have technology.
And sure we have the
technology I just alluded to.
But if you're talking about
technology as life's solution
to problems, then that's
pretty impressive.
You make a list of things that
animals and sometimes very
small animals, 100 million years
ago, invented before we did,
it includes flight,
sonar, magnetic sensing,
infrared sensing, batteries,
polarization sense,
fiber optics, holography.
I could make an
even longer list.
And you might say,
well, yeah, but they
weren't doing it in
labs and with inventions
and wearing white
coats and stuff.
But that's OK.
They just did it.
And then you work
up the chain a bit
and you get maybe the
things that we actually
consider as pets.
You know, so they're
creatures that can talk.
Creatures that have behaviors
that look interesting.
Alex the parrot, connection
to the U of A there,
talkative and playful able to
understand the concept of zero,
which not all humans can do.
Rats, ticklish and curious,
personality traits.
Rats can anticipate sex and
some very beautiful experiments
a decade ago show that they can
reflect on their own thinking.
Metacognition is
quite a high skill.
So maybe we shouldn't
rodents completely.
But you've probably seen this.
This is a crow, never been
in this situation before,
Caledonian crow called Betty.
They like meat.
And there's meat in a basket.
She has a wire.
But it's a straight wire.
There happens to be a
notch cut in the base
of the thing holding the tube.
Again, never been in this
situation, first time.
They use stick in the
wild, but not wire.
She figures she can
turn that into a lever.
That's a real time experiment
and quite impressive.
So that maybe the adjective
birdbrain is a perjorative.
And then we have creatures
that separated us
from the tree of life
in the tree of life
hundreds of millions
of years ago
and that have
extraordinary capabilities.
Cephalopods are shape
shifting creatures
with distributed
brains, where there's
a central brain and a
brain located on each arm.
If the arm is
severed, the arm will
continue to move and camouflage
to distract the predator.
We just don't know how
smart these creatures.
I've talked to divers who have
been led on wild goose chases
through the complex three
dimensional topology of a coral
reef basically
getting the diver lost
and then coming and
retrieving the diver again.
We can't communicate
with these creatures.
That's all.
So these are the aliens that
we co-exist with on the planet.
Maybe we should try
and understand them
first before we see
what we get out there.
And in terms of the ratio
of brain mass to body mass,
we're special.
But we're not like
off the chart.
And some of these small
brains are very, very well
put together packages.
So you go up to
something like an orca,
and it's a pretty close call.
No natural enemies.
We're their only enemy.
Large brains, complex
brains, languages.
The orca pods in
the Puget Sound have
dialects not only at the level
of different pods and sub-pods,
but of family members,
individual family
members or familial groupings.
They are social animals
that raise their young
in the similar proportion
of their total lifespan
to humans raising their young.
And then it starts
to get less clear.
Orcas mate for life.
Statistically we don't.
And I think the
problem with them
is they don't have
opposable thumbs
and so they've never done
this wireless internet stuff.
And they don't have bombs.
And they don't have cars.
That's not really their loss.
They're supremely adapted
to their environment.
But I'll make another point
about evolution and time.
On the left you see the rise
in brain mass corresponding
to the evolutionary surge that
took us to the top of the pile.
Notice that happened over
the last two million years
and in a real surge in
the last 100,000 years.
That brain mass increase is now
plotted in terms of the ratio
to body mass on the right
and the track of the apes
our ancestors and
that recent surge
taking us to encephalization
quotient of 7
on the right edge shown.
And the point is
that an alien coming
to this planet at almost
any time in the last 50
million years and saying, take
me to the brainy creatures,
would have gone to the
whales and the dolphins
and their ancestors.
It's a very recent
thing that we've
become the most encephalized
creatures on Earth.
So it doesn't stand still.
It's a snapshot.
And we don't know how this
plays out in the future.
We have no idea how
evolution how will take us.
Life on earth is already weird.
There's some very weird life
that we've already discussed.
I think in general we could
have levels of weirdness.
At the macroscopic
level, we could really
have different cell
types than we have now.
We could have much more
rapid rates of evolution
based on something that does
happen in life on Earth, which
is swapping of genetic material
in packages, either organisms
co-opting each other
or genetic swamping.
It doesn't have to be the
slow march of mutation and DNA
variation.
And then I think
there's no reason
the universe
couldn't have created
something other than a cell.
You don't need a cell
to have something
that you might call
biology, except you
won't call it biology.
You could have a
network as opposed
to a container that did
everything fundamentally
that biology does.
And then some of these
things could clearly scale up
to the level of a planet.
And you could have
geoengineering of a planet
by creatures that might be
individually at the organism
level quite small.
If you're talking
about the micro level,
there's also possible weirdness.
A variation, a small variation
would be just changing
the genetic code a little bit.
But that's very mild.
That's modest.
Let's go beyond that.
You could go away from the
central dogma of biology,
the triad of DNA,
RNA, and proteins.
Or you could go to
non-carbon based
biology or not using water as
your solvent, as your medium.
And then you could actually--
there's room at the bottom.
Although a human
has a DVD's worth
of information in it the genetic
code, that's pretty impressive.
That's not the
limit of compactness
biochemistry could
attain, in principle.
Now, whether it happens
in practice, who knows?
And so you could have even
higher density and perhaps
a vastly speeded
up scale evolution
with a totally different basis.
So I'm obviously getting
wildly speculating here.
But the point is for exobiology,
we don't know what to expect.
And some of these
forms of life, we
look at the conjunct
of things that
use planets, that
use carbon, that use
DNA as their genetic material.
But the conjunct of those
might be unrecognizable
if one of those things doesn't
apply or none of them apply.
So let's just look a
little into the future
because it's a
snapshot right now.
So what might change?
The singularity, as
you probably know,
is a term invented by Ray
Kurzweil, actually not.
He popularized it.
It was invented before him.
But it's a reference to the fact
that at our stage of evolution,
we may pass through
a membrane where
we become post biological.
And once again, if
we're not special,
if the Copernican
principle applies,
that could have happened
elsewhere in the universe.
And given the time available,
it may well have happened.
And looking at
this, the increase
of information in the
genetic form of evolution
has been dwarfed by cultural
evolution, when we invented
civilization and books,
and then dwarfed yet again
by digital evolution,
our modern technology.
So the rate of information,
encoding, transmittal,
and growth is now 10
to 18 times higher
than it is with biology
alone acting over time.
That's an incredible
acceleration.
If you project Moore's law and
its equivalence in networking,
you actually get
to a position where
you could approximate
the capacity
in the human brain in terms of
network connections in about
20 years.
And remember, this was ENIAC.
And this was a computer
a long time ago
that was in the size of a
family home, took about a third
of the power of
Philadelphia to run it,
had five technicians
full-time changing valves.
And this is 50 times
worse than whatever
cell phone, smartphone
you have in your pocket.
So things don't stand still.
And what matters really is the
capacity of the total package,
not just the processor.
And so people with
robots have shown
how connecting simple machines
that have sensing capability
and linking them
with a neural net,
so it has the capacity
to self-program
and to learn from
its environment,
it's not intelligent, the
intelligence is not put in.
It emerges from the base level.
This creates some
interesting possibilities.
It's machine intelligence,
but of course it's
facilitated by humans.
So after iterations
of this, again,
these behaviors
are not programmed
into the little robots at all.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So here's the point.
We make this prediction
or projection
based on Moore's Law.
This is the history of
computers over almost a century.
And it projects to
a capacity to equal
our capability in robotic
form in about 20 or 30 years.
It depends how you
do the projection.
And, of course,
that could either be
a computer that
can do what we do
or a machine that can
generate the ability
to travel between stars
and colonize the galaxy.
Both of those possibilities
are projected by our capability
within a couple of decades.
And the most important
point is that we don't
have to go there ourselves.
We can send the
machines instead of us.
So a simple model of
tenth light speed travel--
you're not violating
relativity--
can have us colonizing
the galaxies.
And this colonization will
be done by our progeny.
And our progeny
will be machines.
They won't be us.
We're too frail.
We won't go.
So let me just talk about
contemplating the aliens
and what we actually do.
What's the scientific
experiment to do this?
The question, the
central question
in this subject in advance
of finding intelligent life
elsewhere and with such an
expectation of habitable worlds
is, where are they?
And Enrico Fermi asked this
very well posed question back
in 1950, because he knew that
our civilization is so young.
And a very small extrapolation
of what we can do
would have us
traveling the galaxy.
That's simply the fact.
No new technologies
are required.
He also knew that there
were incredibly large number
of sites for life and
an incredibly long time.
There could have been
an Earth-like planet
with an absolute Earth clone,
as close as you could get,
that formed 6 billion years
before the Earth formed
and have that much
of a head start on us
in terms of evolution.
What would that have spawned?
There could be
creatures out there
that are to us as we are
to anaerobic bacteria.
What would that look like?
These are the questions
that we expect.
Nature may have provided.
And we can't answer
these questions.
And so the possible answers
to Fermi are, of course,
diverse, because we
don't know the answer.
But it's possible
they don't exist
and we are a unique accident
as a technological, intelligent
species.
It's possible they're rare
enough that in time and space
we're isolated.
The universe is a big place.
The galaxy is a big place.
It's quite possible they're
either unrecognizable or
inscrutable.
That we don't they're there.
We don't know how
to recognize them.
Their communications, we don't
know how to recognize even
as communications.
And another possibility
is that they don't care.
If we went to a distant
planet and found some lichen
on the surface of a rock and
wrote it in their tricorder,
lichen, not very interesting.
They may be as advanced
to us as we are to lichen.
And so they've already visited
the Earth and just wrote,
hm, humans,
uninteresting, move on.
You know, I mean that's not
the science fiction trope.
But that's possibly
what happened.
And then another possibility is
that they actually created us.
And I'm not going to-- I'm
going to skip ahead a little
here because I'm getting behind.
So let me talk about how
we might make contact.
So this is the scientific
experiment of SETI.
This is not how it's
going to happen.
We're not going to tempt them
with groceries or candy or beer
or anything like that.
It is possible that
they're among us,
which I guess logically
also means among you, or me.
So that's a possibility that
we don't need to look far
because they're already here.
But let me just discount
that for a minute
and say that with what we
know at the moment, the way
we approach the issue of
technological civilizations
and communication with
intelligent aliens
is by looking at the way the
real estate of the Milky Way
reduces when you ask
that it have planets,
that the planets be habitable,
that life actually happens
on those planets
that are habitable,
that there's sufficient
time, and that the occurrence
of intelligence that
intelligence gets technology.
And you can see it's a
diminishing set of terms, which
turns into the Drake equation.
And so the Drake equation
is a simple formula
to calculate the number of
intelligent communicable
civilizations.
And what you'll recognize
is that the first three
terms are astronomical.
The first three
terms are essentially
measured by information
I've given you this evening.
The third, the fourth, fifth,
and sixth and seventh terms
are indeterminate.
We have no idea what they are.
And so you can get
any N you want.
And that's just the state
we're in at the moment.
What have we done?
We've sent little
messages in a bottle.
This was attached to the
Pioneer 10 spacecraft, now left
the solar system.
This was attached to
the Voyager spacecraft,
now left the solar system.
And you could critique
it because we don't even
use that technology on Earth
that we're really showing them
how clever we are, aren't we.
Well, OK, I know
there are audiofiles
that do-- the scientists
involved actually
defended this because
they said it's actually
very robust, analog technology.
We don't know the
longevity of DVDs or CDs.
There's already
signs they degrade.
So this will last 100,000
years, not a bad idea.
So here's the real
state of the experiment.
If you know anything
about the search
for extraterrestrial
intelligence,
mostly using radio signals
and more recently using
optical pulsed lasers,
you'll know that we've
had 50 years of silence.
But the people who do this work
are an indomitable species,
because they don't
get discouraged
by 50 years of failure.
I think I would go away
with my tail between my legs
after probably a decade.
But they're some of them
have been plugging away
for 50 years, like
Frank Drake himself.
But it's getting interesting
because they are projecting
that within a decade or so
we will have the capacity
to listen to our analog
technology of radio
transmitters or pulse lasers
on any of 100 million stars
at distances of up
to 3,000 light years.
That's pretty impressive.
That means if any
civilization on planets
around any of 100 million stars
are transmitting information
by those two methods,
we could detect it.
And they could detect us.
And I do think that makes
an interesting scientific
experiment.
And they'll just point
out that we've only
just got into the regime
where we have this capability.
So it's a transient thing.
You know, you're only going
detect civilizations that
are somewhere near your
stage of development,
because in 50 years we'll
be making baby universes
and slinging gravity
waves at each other.
And we'll be doing other things.
We're not going to be using
lasers and radio transmitters.
We'll do something else.
A less comfortable
possibility is
that there are very advanced.
And I have mentioned
one possibility
of them being very advanced
is that they don't care.
Another one sort of brings
down our sense of ourselves
because they might view us
a slightly different way.
And that's sort of the
Stephen Hawking scenario
where we sort of don't want
to make contact because we
don't want to know the answer.
So to conclude, let me give you
the census of habitable worlds.
Let me give you the full
real estate that's out there.
And you can do the
math in your head
of what you think the likelihood
of life on those planets
is, because we don't know.
So you can put in
the number you like.
So here's an analogy.
Let's use grains of
sand, because at least we
can visualize this.
The numbers are too
large otherwise.
The number of grains of sand
you could put on your finger
if you wet your
fingertip may be 500.
That's how many
exoplanets we found.
stars nearby, really
nearby, within
tens of light years
we've looked at since 1995.
These are mostly
the giant planets,
the terrestrial planets are
motes, too small to see.
We expect, based
on the numbers I've
given you in the Kepler results,
a billion habitable worlds
in the Milky Way galaxy alone.
Probably 10% of those will be
terrestrial Earth-like planets,
not total Earth clones, but
pretty close, spitting distance
from Earth, 100 million.
Then remember, previous
lectures, 100 billion galaxies
in the observable universe.
That means the number
of habitable planets
in the universe is the grains of
sand on the entire arc of beach
miles long.
That is a conservative,
traditional habitable zone
with liquid water
on the surface,
using current statistics.
That's what the
universe has provided.
Do you prefer that those
billion billion habitable worlds
are all sterile?
That life happened
on none of them?
What fraction do you
think it happened on?
And assuming it happens
on some fraction,
what fraction of those do you
think the experiment persists
long enough for something
interesting like this
to happen?
It's an interesting question.
And it's well motivated,
well conceived.
And we may actually
start to get the answer.
This travelogue is a
snapshot of how difficult
this experiment is.
You're seeing an exoplanet,
an imagined distant world,
every five seconds.
And we don't know
what they look like.
Most of them will be sterile.
Most of them will
be uninteresting.
Most of them will be dead.
In this travelogue where
one exoplanet is every five
seconds, to just
do a snapshot view
of the truly Earth-like
habitable worlds in the Milky
Way alone would
take 5,000 years.
That's how much real
estate there is.
To do it in the
universe, forget it.
There's not enough
geological time to do it.
So this is the experiment
that's underway.
It's at the limit
of our technologies.
It's really hard to do.
Finding Earth is going to be the
challenge of the next decade.
And we will find Earths.
They won't be close.
They won't be easy to follow up.
Those traces of life
will be hard to find.
But I think the game is now on.
And that's very exciting.
In my last video clip, I want to
pay homage to is a hero of mine
and a hero of many
of my colleagues
actually, who conceived of most
of these ideas, who laid out
the landscape of
astrobiology decades
before planets around other
stars were discovered,
Carl Sagan.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - CARL SAGAN, "A GLORIOUS
DAWN"]
I'm not very good
at singing songs.
But here's a try.
This is him updated a little.
Ah, whoop.
Ah, ah. whoop.
If you wish to make an
apple pie from scratch,
you must first
invent the universe.
Space is filled with a
network of wormholes.
You find yourself
somewhere else in space,
some-when else in time.
The sky calls to us.
If we do not destroy
ourselves, we well one day
venture to the stars.
A still more glorious dawn
awaits, not a sunrise,
but a galaxy rise.
A wormhole filled 400
billion suns and the rising
of the Milky Way.
The cosmos is full
beyond measure.
Elegant truths, exquisite
interrelationships,
the awesome machinery of nature.
I believe our future
depends powerfully
on how we understand
this cosmos, which
we float like a mote of
dust on the morning sky.
The brain does more
than recollect.
It inter-compares.
It synthesizes.
It analyzes.
It generates abstractions.
The simplest thought, like
the concept of the number one,
has a logical underpinning.
The brain has its own language,
for testing the structure
and consistency of the world.
A single, glorious dawn
awaits, not a sunrise,
but a galaxy rise.
A morning filled with 400
billion suns and the rising
of the Milky Way.
The sky calls to us.
If we do not destroy
ourself, we will one day
venture to the stars.
For 1,000 some years, people
have about the universe.
Did it stretch out forever
or was there a limit?
From the Big Bang to black
holes, from dark matter
to a possible big crunch, our
image of the universe today
is full strange sounding ideas.
How lucky we are to
live in this time.
The first moment
in human history
we are in fact
visiting other worlds.
A still more glorious dawn
awaits, not a sunrise,
but a galaxy rise.
A morning to 400 billion suns,
the rising of the Milky Way.
A still more dawn awaits. not
a sunrise, but a galaxy rise.
A morning filled
400 billion suns,
with the rising
of the Milky Way.
The surface from the Earth is
the shore of the cosmic ocean.
Recently, we waded
out a little way out
and the water seems inviting.
[END PLAYBACK]
Well, we thank you
very much for coming.
A big round of applause
for Chris Impey.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]